All right, FashionTV.
So we've got with me the lovely Jessica Michibata...
...who's causing quite a commotion here in Isetann.
Yes.
As a talented designer, tell me, what goes into creating these lovely bags?
Well, I always try to come up with a theme, first of all,...
...and obviously, I wanna design a bag that I'll actually use as well.
So I always come up with, I would say, I don't know, some kind of icon...
...and also try to make it useful as well at the same time.
And Samantha Thavasa is such an iconic Japanese brand...
...so I wanna keep that "kawaii," you know, cute.
"Kawaii" means "cute."
Yes.
I learnt that when we were in Japan.
Exactly, so I wanna keep that feel as well in my bag collection.
They're quite girlie and quite feminine bags, aren't they?
Oh yes.
Lots of pink, lots of bows and hearts and lots of all the cute stuff.